ben shapiro editor-in-chief of daily
wire.com and richard fowler nationally
syndicated radio talk show host and a
fox news contributor richard you know
i'm just watching this and it isn't
really that i'm that's surprising i mean
you know when you look at all of the
things that Maxine Waters has said since
since the inauguration but I can't help
but wonder if you know previous
president President Obama or you know
President Clinton if someone had stood
up and said that about them don't you
think the outrage on the other side
would have been uncontainable and I
think the outrage was uncontainable when
Ted Nugent threatened to shoot the
president there was outrage on the left
and it was uncontainable so I and here's
the thing it's not a good woman now no I
mean I get that and I don't think that
she was threatening to kill the
president in this particular soundbite I
think that some from the right have sort
of made this idea that she's trying to
threaten to kill him I don't think
that's what she's saying here I think
you're saying I'll go take them out just
like somebody like the president would
say I'm gonna go take out Hillary
Clinton beat her in the next election
right it's a very tongue-in-cheek saying
I mean she's been in Congress since 1991
nobody believes that she's going to go
to the White House to try to harm
physically harm the president anyway has
devolved so dramatically on all sides
that this is just sort of the way we
talk now Ben what do you think I think
there's some truth to that I think
there's a pretty outstanding example of
just how far the rhetoric has devolved I
mean Maxine Waters has been saying
pretty inflammatory a career there's a
woman who once said that the LA riots
were really enough la uprising she's
used charged language for for 20 odd
years she's one of most corrupt members
of Congress I don't think anyone's
particularly surprised by this but the
the shouting and cheering for the idea
that I'm gonna take him out tonight it's
for tonight that really adds that extra
flavour there it's not just I'm gonna
take him out in 2018 or 2020 it's we're
gonna take him out tonight that I think
everyone's upset about and sort of
rightfully so all right
I just want think I want to say I mean
is the prep the president's rhetoric is
almost just as bad he said he could
shoot somebody on Fifth Avenue and still
be elected president of the United
States right so there's his rhetoric is
just as bad so I mean I think to sit
here and to criticize maxima
congresswoman waters we should also be
criticized as a product president for
using the same type of rhetoric well we
said no is that where we
the conversation devolved to such an
extent that we you know we just sort of
take this as as no big deal
speaking of rhetoric let's take a look
at this cartoon that was put out in The
Daily Californian which sounds like a
Sunday newspaper but that's what they
they published its Alan Dershowitz with
his head sort of pushed through you know
some sort of wall and the images that
are back there depict stomping on the
Palestinian flag and an Israeli soldier
shooting an unarmed person and let's
also put up the what Alan Dershowitz
showed us in terms of what was put up at
the University on the bulletin board
where his there was a swastika drawn
over his face been I mean it's pretty
shockingly anti-semitic stuff this
particular cartoon is straight from the
pages of their Sturmer
appearing in the berkeley newspaper the
suggestion that Alan Dershowitz is a
tool of the Israelis and not only a tool
of the Israelis the Israelis are engaged
in not cska occupation in which they're
killing innocent children for no reason
at all and this is it's pretty obvious
you know anti-zionism equaling
anti-semitism in this particular case
let's put up a quote from an interview
that you guys did at the Daily wire comm
with Alan Dershowitz and you know he
points out he's irony is to kind of word
it's hypocrisy and remember this is a
reaction to a speech in which I said
that I support a Palestinian state and
he goes on to say I support the end of
the occupation I'm against Israeli
policies on settlements you know and
Richard it just raises the question of
whether or not there's some similarities
between you know sort of the hard the
hard progressive left and and this
neo-nazi hard right listen I've said all
along I think that there's racism on
both sides of the aisle I don't care how
you split the cookie I think there's
racism in the Democratic Party
I think there's racism and the
Republican Party I think is homophobia
and the Democratic Party I think there's
homophobia in the Republican Party I
don't think homophobia racism xenophobia
sexism I don't think they no party
affiliation I think there's hate in
people's hearts and there's nothing you
can do a pot do about it and I don't
think it hides under one particular
political cloak or another
period
I mean I think that there's there some
truth to that the question is how close
is that hate to the heart of a
particular movement and when you're
talking about the anti-zionism
anti-semitism some parts of the left
that seems a lot closer to the heart
Democratic Party then to the heart of
the Republican so thanks